the last word
all right and we are live welcome to the
last word with more Cognito any partisan
seems like we got some legendary company
here to KFI it was what's going on today
do we do yeah so the choice of guardian
con and twitter have entered estes
introduced us to some amazing people and
some have the talents that i will never
hold in the world artists so I'm glad my
eyes can behold this art but I won't let
you introduce our guests because we're
very lucky to have them here with us
today
absolu you know we gotta do that
treatment all right let's do it
welcome to the last word episode number
95 it's not the glorious Friday we're
back in front of the campfire for some
more ludus shorter discussion I'm
extremely excited about our special
guests so we gonna get right into it I
want to introduce a lord who boxes and I
had the pleasure of meeting in the flesh
at Guardian con 2019 none others Lord a
fixture in the community for his
outstanding artwork in the Destiny
universe but his signature rugged style
a meticulous attention to detail truly
separate his work into that masterpiece
category introducing the freelance slash
independent artist of Brian Marcos art
calm the legend whose artwork has grace
my name is bite PlayStation 4 game
informer and bungie.net and is still the
lord of the charcoal brush live from GA
and making his debut in to the campfire
of the last word
my man know what Brian Marcus how you
doing sir quiet an intro thank you
welcome let's do it baby we got a roll
of red carpet everybody's locked in so
we gonna keep you guys entertained for a
little while but yeah thank you for
joining us Brian we've greatly greatly
appreciate that thank you guys much
thank you
much appreciate it man
they'll still be getting a lot of desti
in recently hasn't been gone with that
with that statement mmm well here and
there we're actually in the process of
moving so it's kind of tough but uh yeah
I've been getting my time in working are
you like packing or unpacking or like
planning to go we are well my wife is
doing more of the packing I'm actually
doing a lot of the renovation so my time
has been limited in that regard
gotcha moving is no joke it takes a lot
out of here so we can understand it man
what's begoña what's your brother uh
well let's see
having a job in somewhat of the fitness
world and now having that basically on
kind of is I've been playing a lot more
playing lots of lots of games and jumped
onto neo2 last night got my butt smashed
for a while which part did you catch did
you catch like after I beat that one guy
the guy was stuck he was fighting some
well boss I was just like I don't want
to know how you memorize these patterns
he had like the big sword you were
trying to rolled up it's a big huge boss
I was like I don't know how you do it to
me it's like God bless you Dark Souls
players like that is torture like that
right there
I don't know how y'all do it but
literally I would end up being a dude I
was listening to you say like I could
never like be a guy that thought I could
show it that game would probably make me
break protocol and throw a controller
just the first part so like I played
blood-borne
that was my first Souls game and the
opening of blood-borne is literally
built to break you but also teach you
they gave me at the same time this one
you have like this optional boss which
is apparently like a cousin as the chat
was helping me out last night and like
you literally walk in you fight one dude
if you've ever played in here you're
like okay I can fight one dude and then
boss but it's not even a full boss it's
just like a dude roaming in a circle you
can choose to fight him or not I think I
fought him for like two damn hours and
then I was like okay so I did finally
beat him but I will definitely say his
cousin when I got to the end of
level much easier because I practiced
for a while and so but yeah we've got a
new you've got a new weapon in the game
got the tab list got a video up about
that get a weapon review been playing
working on leveling I can see four
digits in my power level now okay it's
it's the artifact I'm gonna blame the
artifact completely moving brother you
moving man I got I got a catch up bad
it's better it's been a busy time for me
obviously all everything that's going on
in the world we all know a little bit
the virus we shot that name for D
monetization purposes seriously whatever
but all doubt seriously but all yeah man
just been trying to get back into it
today I saw it all horse been dropped
and uh just getting some crucible
preparing for trials you know say so
just pretty much it me and of course I
had that uh
amazing Osirian warlock Frank get me
ready I suppose evasion when I go into
trial Israel had cop that new Marcus
flavor do you give it like an Osiris
fair I'm one with the brother brother
Vance Chloe vehicle I'm big a fan Osiris
than brunt of it so we come by got to
talk to him Vance's still sit down the
mercury really guys quick if you don't
mind I was going to ask you know our
special guest couple questions
you never say just said reference to you
know I'm saying this journey and stuff
like that and obviously you know we all
know him for his outstanding artwork I
mean you know we don't have to keep
comment if you watch from my video
literally this is him facts that this is
the work so um one thing I noticed I
want to say if your work is that I love
is to be always have like a lot of
signature darker tones more mature tones
and destiny like what first was your art
in general how'd you get started with
that and then with DES T what kind of
made you pivot to that style of art um
that's a loaded question
we're here we got time well getting
started in art there's kind of been a
lifelong journey started when I was kid
you know that sort of thing
through high school kept doing it kept
doing it had nice motivation from my
parents which is always great and then
went to art college and majored in
sequential art and animation okay and
did a little bit of work there came out
I did not graduate came out four years
later and started working at a bank not
art related kept doing it on the side
then social media came out like I say
came out didn't it
and the end started playing destiny and
sort of just fell into the community and
then that's where most of my work has
gotten is is its exposure really the
short version of it but uh but yeah I
mean nihilistic alee yeah I don't know
man it's just something I've always
enjoyed doing like more realistic stuff
I come from a traditional charcoal
portraiture background charcoals yeah
that's that's that's where it comes from
so like when procreate came out my the
way that the program procreate works
it's very very friendly to the way that
I'm used to drawing so I've started
drawing they're more charcoal like stuff
again and now I'm trying to get better
at painting Wow take it to the next
little shout out shout out the lady
boxes she said Oh his wife bought him
how do you bla Cintiq is that people
most clueless not artistic people no
yeah that's I figured most people
probably wouldn't know so like a tablet
is like something you can plug up to
your computer and you'd be able to draw
on the tablet be like you're drawing on
the screen that's a basic tablet that
you can get for any kind of digital
artwork a Cintiq is it can be sort of a
tablet but there's also some that are
basically computers but you draw
directly on the screen
they're pretty pricey I think the one
that she got me surprised me with was
around $2,000 Wow
and I wouldn't have gotten it otherwise
because I just wasn't prepared to make
that kind of investment in myself but if
she hadn't have gotten that for me
probably wouldn't and progress this
Boras idea salute debate Bach his ass
but she is absolutely awesome awesome
have to have a supporting relationship
for anything that you do so that's great
absolutely and then a couple highlights
at one point on on obviously the truck
talked about the you know the
PlayStation 4 thing that was really cool
getting that that cover as far as that
wallpaper obviously working with the
legend I called him my name was back the
law engine then you had a you what you
said on a game of Game Informer like
tell us about a couple of opportunities
man out of those poeple off so a game
informer actually came it's a lot of
this stuff is revolves around who you
know better that kind of to kind of sum
things blood on a life you learn as you
get older yeah so in 2016 was raspberry
is that right am I right on that was
rather barren selves right yeah yeah
that sounds right yeah that sounds about
right
do you want us for mmm-hmm yeah so when
rods of iron came out game informer had
a contest where you could submit your
artwork for a cover for rise of iron not
not for rise of iron but for a cover to
Game Informer so to speak but they
weren't gonna use it as a cover they
were just using it as a competition and
you would get like a Stein copy of your
piece with the Game Informer logo signed
by Bungie employees now oh so there was
three winners that was the first time
that I want anything destiny related and
it looks nothing like the stuff that I
do now but that contact that I had from
that specific event
contacted me I guess a year or so later
when d2 came out about doing the Game
Informer or
interview okay and that's how that
happened
and then of course like the stuff that
later happened like the ps4 thing that
happened be from Guardian Con 2018 when
I went I actually met one of the Bungie
I forget her actual title but she was
kind of over the you want to call it
kind of like a head of a specific yeah
like customer relation Nations okay um
but yeah I met her and I want to say
that they she probably had a hand in
this but when PlayStation went to Bungie
about finding an artist to do the ps4
theme mm-hmm they recommended me as one
of the artists oh that's where that came
from
hi and yeah so everything else kind of
fell into place and then the by thing of
course I you know talked to bike on and
off for quite a long time and we we had
been planning to do something and but
that's that just kind of that came about
due to just you know a more exposure and
being around you know being talking to
people more often than umbrellas
networking brother yeah yeah yeah shout
to you at happy I mean obviously I
remember the game of font it's the storm
caller or piece yeah that was the that
was the game informer one that was the
one that I did for the actual article
that they putting in yeah I'm totally
looking at it right now kind of black
and white with the mountain top and like
the thorn down and the head looks really
cool
oh yes - yeah are you talking about the
informer reservoir know what I'm looking
at yeah that's the game informer rods
bearing it was nothing like what I do
now yeah but I mean like it's it's just
a different style it's not I mean it's
damn good - yes yes so how do you go I
mean do you just have a lot of styles
you just kind of choose what you go to
cuz I've seen a tendency length of your
recent art has its you know feel to it
and then is the reason you make a jump
or what makes you want to change a
complete soul or is it just like an
evolution of what you've like built on
it's a it's a little bit of all of that
so as a younger person as an artist you
you're kind of like always searching for
what
your own style but you're also copying
artists that you enjoy and that you you
like and I've always been a fan a fan of
like comics and things like that so like
there's a lot of comic artists that you
know enjoy their work and Joe mad had a
big influence on me coming up when I was
in high school and middle school so that
played a role in a lot of my pencil
artwork and then the more I skewed
towards charcoal and stuff was from
college and that had a lot to do with
like classical artists like like legit
like old masters and things like that
like the you know you tell Michelangelo
da Vinci Rembrandt on one lung so with
that combined with the other it just
kind of all melts together and that
earlier stuff that you're looking at
that was before I really got into
procreate and some of the other programs
are available today so everything I do
now I would feel is definitely more raw
me like than than before because I was
limited on the tools that I could use
digital in the back then got you that
was gonna she disliked again we talked
offline come obviously my one of my
favorites is that Oh Syrian war likely
and that Osiris you don't say fanboy and
me was loving all that so you got that
money early don't worry but I wanted to
ask another one of my favorite pieces is
all actually the more expand the Kings
fall that is amazing because one thing I
like that you did is the sense of scale
and you seeing that you know them saying
eat the Guardians it feels like how you
you would feel going in in that rate
itself you're gonna say so it's like I
wanted to shot like how did you um get
to that whole thought process how long
did it take you to kind of make your
pieces and that one in particular cuz I
think that was a really iconic one for
me in my P um that one was
I mean I'd always wanted to do an
aurochs piece I haven't done oh I worked
piece I think I've done a portrait of
him in charcoal but um I've never done a
actual completed version of him so I was
like well I mean I'll do one and then I
you know I always thought it was really
cool like the whole Kings fall raid was
just amazing and I didn't quite get to
experienced it as much because I was
back in d1 I played more by myself than
anything but I did watch it I did watch
the world's first kill with once it was
bro man and Gotham them and just that
whole fight was just so cool to me and I
kind of wanted just a you know it mortal
eyes that moment a little bit absolutely
as iconic yeah mmhmm shot at the fk
before taste the best rate of destiny
yes I do I don't you guys about it but
it's a big heated debated there as far
as reigns but I've always respected
Kings for I've always said it's it I
wouldn't be mad at anyone who has it as
their favorite ring you know there's so
it's in the pantheon it's just it's a
like Oryx just I mean we haven't seen 17
yet but like out of all the bosses in in
destiny so far I'll give you that Boris
was just such a Skippy that um
- he's just the whole his whole demeanor
was just like bad I mean again he just
wanted death but I mean it was even the
arm the I don't know which mission it is
the thing that's one of the first and
last missions in d1 in the taken King
campaign that you go through yes when
when he's manifest and he's just the way
he's talking to you like felonies like
feed your life to me and all this stuff
the way he speaks and everything or I
guess the voice actor that does it's
just looks sick man I just like but
there's no other to me there's no other
boss in the game that has been that like
I don't know I don't give it to you
because I got said I mean we've had the
chat is already started right now with
the fighting being rated White House
says this I'll be obviously they know
I'm a big faulty glass fan but I think
you I have to give this to you like you
said as far as the difficulty you idiots
have this car
that's why I call it like a real man's
ray you know as far as how difficult
wasn't but like you said more about Oryx
and I think what was great about it is
how they led the story into it and then
you had that epic conclusion where the
raid continued the story and he's larger
than life so yeah I agree I gotta give
it up there on that left II well you go
to I know this is this on your list I
know you're smiling right now just like
browsing through and I'm like I'm
looking at some of some of the ones that
I've liked like before I think the one
that like set me because warlock over
there for kognito very much a warlock
and then when you did the the you what
you call the Devastator the one-eyed
mask with the hammer dude yeah that one
late that was one of the ones I'd
watched the art like the aurochs one was
cool like so many and then that one I
was just like for me being like a Titan
I was just like damn cuz I've always
like as soon as them as in taken king
when the fire tightened the the hammer
Titan came out that's when I switched
from playing Hunter and d1 to Titan and
that was like when you encapsulated that
when I was just like oh it's a beast and
then of course what I'd mask having it
to run for the longest time but ya know
there's so many in here that are just
there's yeah they're so epic I've done a
lot and honestly I love the pieces that
I've done but it's it's weird because
I've learned so much when it comes to
color and paint application and digital
I'm still learning but I've learned so
much in such a short amount of time
because each thing that I do I learn
something new and it's not small things
you just usually big things and I'll go
back and I'm like I really wish I'd have
done this oh okay you know what I'm
saying like that I'm happy when I
complete them but then about a couple of
pieces later I go back and I'm like man
this would've looks so much cooler if
I'd have done it this way so one where
you seeing like were you what's what
were you can look back and be like one
now for like an older example that's
when you see that you could want to okay
like a lot of the a lot of the way that
some of those first ones were done where
I would complete a black and white
drawing which it's not uncommon to do an
under drawing or a painting yeah but
what I would do is I would successively
lay layers over that of color in
different overlays and different types
of layer modes and procreate no which is
not uncommon but there is a big
difference in how those layers get
applied to the arm to the overlay versus
actually opaquely painting over
something it's just a different look and
if you look at like some of my newer
stuff um this is hard to explain now
getting really really technical if you
look at like for instance the hunter
yeah um did I just did the whale and
glue gun yeah the golden grin mm-hmm
a lot of that it's not uh not a lot of
it pretty much pretty much all of it was
painted opaquely over the top of a very
very messy under drawing I did not
finish the under drawing before I went
through and painted over that and it's
not perfect but it's also way way way
different in process than the way I've
done the others and I'm getting more
used to painting a peg Lea over
something versus doing lots and lots of
layers which you know it's hard to show
you what that would look like on the
older ones but let me just tell you it
would make it wouldn't make a world of
difference in how the how the colors
come forward and how the shadows recede
and it's just different I can't explain
it but it does have a different look
would ya it looking through some of the
older ones like even from Oryx and then
Saladin saint-14 Osiris they have a
darker tone I guess almost like a darker
feel and then when you throw it when you
go kind of to the newer ones I think I
mean you kind of said it's like the
colors are more vibrant the lightening
on way of the current pops even just
baby which I love the baby I saw that
I did a lot of opaque painting in that
particular painting versus the the other
ones and the way of the current had some
- that was when I really started doing
it but the ones prior to that like the
Saladin like you mentioned it being
darker and that's a lot of the reasons
because he was done with a very light
charcoal type history from me because
I'm used to doing like a lot of dark
like heavy heavy darks and he'll like a
little bit of light yeah because that's
how you get good contrast in like a in a
drawing if you're gonna do like a
charcoal drawing but anyway when I go to
a plot color or something like that you
can only apply color over the areas that
are lit so to speak I mean you can do
tinted shadows but it's just not it just
doesn't work out as well the way I was
doing the process so like as I
progressed to got better at adding color
a lot of my color a lot of my paintings
got more lighter like as in like more
[Laughter]
listen if you ever you know what every
visit you know Osiris with these dual
techniques you let your boy know I got
to pre-order ready okay if you ever want
to decide to revisit that I would never
I'll never do another Osiris simply
simply because like the dude has too
many damn feathers I don't know what I
could understand I could understand that
yeah his his outfit is very intricate
and I can see as an artist how that
could be extremely annoying but yo you
killed that and I'm looking at it right
now yo but it's at everybody like I said
if you want to get an idea what we're
talking about please go to Brian
Marcus art comm has a lot of his pieces
up right now just kind of like browsing
through and yeah man it is but nominal
you gots Agera in there like when I saw
you put again you put me on to that and
I was just like wow the level of detail
and
and like you said with the charcoal and
just that that dark but sure tone that's
what I love about your stuff it's like
your artwork Destiny's not a happy place
is it it's real out here pretty tough
time too rough so I wanted to ask are
there like are there any ones that
you've like wanted to do or do you have
like this just a list of things that you
want to do or stuff you haven't got to
or they're things you've thought about
but you're like maybe it doesn't fit my
style or the ones that are like pending
out there that you like you know would
look forward to or ones that you like
I've thought about and you're like maybe
just not I'm just kind of curious of the
ones that haven't quite made it through
to the to the canvas per se I mean yeah
like there's a lot of them that are
hanging out there I have a lot of roughs
that I've done that I haven't followed
through yet for one reason or another
and in all honesty like I've done a lot
of destiny or work game and it's not
that it gets to a point to where it's
boring it's just that I have to get to
like trials or anything else I have to I
have to get to a point of inspiration
yes because there gets to it gets to be
monotonous when you're just like oh let
me see what else I'm one of what are the
armor I want to draw you know and I've
gotten to the point now where almost it
takes like saint-14 or something like
that like I was completely inspired to
do another saint-14 piece when I thought
they were bringing him back I was just
you know and I'd already done a saint-14
if it hadn't been for that I probably
would have done another one because I
was just I just didn't feel no reason to
but you know when I saw him in the
trailer it's like yep I I just I have a
different feeling for him now I have so
much more under my belt as far as what
I've learned so I want to do another one
mm-hmm
you know but it takes that really for me
now I like trials I've been meaning to
do the trials armor um because I loved
it from d1 and when they brought it back
I was just like you know it's just been
something I've been wanting to do for
quite a while so I'm gonna I'm gonna
throw these together I yeah okay I'm
sorry no just to say that's kind of what
it takes these days for me I have to
have some inspiration sometimes they you
leave it yeah that's that's the best
that's when you're something your best
work comes right I mean
in the day when you got that passion
behind it to do it it's gonna motivate
you to go through as opposed to like an
assembly line of requests for people or
yeah that's hard I have plenty of
respect for the people that can do
Commission after Commission yeah and
it's not that I don't enjoy drawing for
people but my best work and I don't
honestly say that just about any artist
best work is always gonna come from
within themselves when they when they're
doing something that comes from their
heart or comes from their soul place of
inspiration that's gonna be their best
stuff every time hands down no respect
it you got me you got anything what's
here you have a next one coming or is
that hunter kind of like taking a break
since then um no I have I'm gonna do the
Titan I've already I'm working on the
broken oil
rough sketch right now nice yeah because
I had to say the best for last I feel
about two Titans get together I respect
that I buy they're not about to give me
a war like that I respect respect you've
got it right now respect
big time big time yeah the other
questions you got for that before we get
to the show uh no I was gonna ask like
just for a general time for one of these
pieces I guess was gonna say like how
many hours do you think you put into a
piece I mean I know some are gonna be
more or less like even if like the older
ones take longer the newer ones are more
efficient or vice versa I'm just kind of
curious I'm like timeframe on some of
those just I mean people say up there
and be like hey that prints 15 bucks but
it's like for you it's like how many
hours did you slave over those things
it's like it's fair so just you know is
I've learned a lot I've learned how to
speed myself up and ways especially this
last one I did it in three days working
time for weight for me which is not
three days of full working hours but in
my world that
like probably a maximum of at most six
hours a day but that's from start to
finish and I think more or less like
what it's not so much it is time
involvement but it's also knowledge and
experience because a year ago I could
have easily spent twenty five thirty
hours on the one that I just did and now
I'm using a different process still
happy with the result and doing probably
half the time at that you know and it's
it's the the time you put in is
important but there's nothing quite like
paying someone or something that like if
you were gonna Commission one or
something like that there's nothing like
paying someone for the knowledge and
skill they have because a lot of that
stuff you know people sitting there and
say like you know how long you been
drawing or I wish I could draw like that
but like you know it's just time lucky
you got a is trial and error it's
repetition and I get five thousand hours
in yeah fine to spend that twenty hours
on that one piece I wouldn't have
learned the little things that I did to
apply to the net and it's like a stand
on you know actually a question for you
I just thought about it like obviously
you know we know your passion you do it
as you're doing you're doing all these
things got only things going on now we
do know that a bungee Hannah has an art
team would you ever like let's just say
an opportunity presents oh would you
ever consider like I'll be doing some
different bungee or you like your your
freedom of like kind of doing what you
do and having the versatility of doing
other things outside of destiny
you know that's um that's something that
this past year is the first time I
actually ever thought about that
seriously um I actually applied to
Bungie twice for concept artist type
positions which you know I figured you
would that's what I was actually gonna
say it was like what would you do
concept probably probably but you know I
dunno how the concept art world works
it's not as it's not as you know it's
different I mean you get you're you're
talking about a very fast-paced and
and people who have to pump out artwork
extremely quickly in a very professional
but you know I would I think more so
this year I've weighed you know if
somebody put both on the table for me
and said look you know you could stream
every day and you could do what you're
doing now and make a living off but I've
it'd be comfortable or you could work at
Bungie for instance and do a concept
artist job and become or which one and
in all honesty I probably would go with
the twitch or when the streaming slash
you know the more freelance entrepreneur
type type field because in the end it
doesn't matter if you're doing art work
if you're just if you're always creating
for somebody else and you're never
really your own I feel that you know is
in a job situation I mean you can always
do that on the side no matter what
you're doing but like if you wanted to
really love your job as an artist you're
gonna want the freedom create what you
want to I mean it's just that's just
what it comes down to and if if you have
a job or as an artist if you're making
money mm-hmm living and doing that then
you've got it made yes that's the
ultimate position
great answer very great is I respect it
I respect it big time that's what I get
in oh you got support questions oh no I
mean we could save here and pick his
brain for hours but honestly just those
time lapses that you do keep I love
those time lapses and they're probably
not easy to sit there and like record
the capture say but they are not
procreate records them in the background
for you oh wow I have to do is export
the video and then add a little bit of
intro endings type transitions and some
music and I'm good to go
yeah I could watch I can watch those on
every piece that you do so those come in
that's only because I slice to see the
development like here's this one like
the eyes here it's like you have your
shrink and they like just the little
developers did you all the little things
that you do is like the changes you go
through it's like okay this is kind of
where it started and if you like take
the initial sketch then there's like not
the biggest changes but they're like you
see why you like I don't know it's just
it's cool development so yes please
don't
but yeah we we are a destiny podcast but
yeah shout out to this man by the way if
you're on video this is gonna look weird
for just a second but I really don't
care because I want to shout out this
man for one more thing and it's the
shirt there so it's masterpiece right
anyway yeah this whole game of destiny -
obviously we got two Titans one warlock
in here tonight so that's uh let's hold
it down against the evil yeah hey don't
worry chef I think chat is like all
hunters right now so we get a good
balance there's a lot of hunters in PvP
what No so noose new week and got a
quest we got a trailer for the quest so
I wanted to ask us before we even got
the quest we got a trailer the quest was
coming on - like a couple hours before
it drops did you guys and this kind of a
question I had four others out there did
you guys like the fact that it was a
trailer did the fact that we knew how it
was coming do you want more of a
surprise like they had the calendar
fairly vague mm-hmm and then somebody
I've replied was like hey what do you
guys think it's a trailer do you like
the this is exactly what you're getting
today versus there's a quest and go
figure out what its gonna be so before
we get into like the process of it and
stuff I want to ask you guys just about
the delivery of the trailer and the
announcement stuff and the fact that
it's you know we know what we're getting
going in did you guys like that are you
okay with it yeah name what Marcus man
how you feel about like knowing ahead of
time
you mean like the trailer for boys but
fourth Horseman yep I'm okay with it
I'm kind of used to it at this point me
personally I'm a fan of those surprise
things like so like when we get a new
expansion drop or new DLC or something
like that our safety LZ that's all it
seasons mom
if it would be cool if like we're just
everybody's just playing and then it's
just like oh look what is this you know
and then Oh looking over here and do
this and no look there's you know
something it's not a quest here we don't
know what it's for
we have no idea and then everybody's
like how did you get that and like oh it
dropped off of some random thing you
know um like to me that gets people kind
of more going than the height which i
think is what they're trying to do with
some of these trailers which i get it in
the you know I get it but I don't know
I'm just I'm just a fan of like seeing
that stuff just pop up out of nowhere it
really surprises people you know that's
my tape yeah I mean I saw your tweets I
knew this was coming actually predicted
you a nasty replied to me and Bungie
replied to them and I was like yeah they
had an opinion um I'm in the middle I
mean I agree with y'all for the most
part is something special about the
surprise of not knowing right there's
something really cool when you log into
destiny and like like you know I can say
like what is that you know saying and
the whole community is trying to figure
that thing out and it's cool um I got I
mean the point where I like is if
there's a balance with it I'm cool if
they're starting to do this for like
every exotic or every quest that's
coming then I'm gonna like I have a
problem with you know saying because of
like you've taken away two mystery from
the game and I the game still needs that
you know to be honest no disrespect
before husband like I was like four
horsemen gets a Chandler plate I never
maybe I'm a hater I never really got
crazy for that gun indeed one I've never
jumped from the ceiling it was like oh
like it's never been that for me so I I
was surprised like the way they were
acting like it was low-key gala horns
coming back and I'm just like you know
this is a hospital in the Gjallarhorn
trailer but yeah oh no I'm gonna be a
hater
I was I was just surprised that four
horsemen was the choice to do a trailer
for you know say that's all but other
than that you know all right let's see
how it goes you know moving forward
probably would
for the surprise yeah that's it but I
know you got a lot on this e what you
think no I mean I'm kinda with you guys
and it's tough because Fabian strategy
trailer
that's a lay lock trailer now if they
did a trailer glass weapon then you're
good till a lock was still a beast
actually but it's oh yeah whoa yeah it
was no I mean for me it's the I get that
we get the trailer I'm like cool I know
it's coming we get the quest then you
know we'll talk about the quest itself
but I was just still I'm with you guys
like I want a little bit of the surprise
be like hey there's a quest today even
if you go up to st. 14 or you go
somewhere and he's like hey go do this
thing and we've got this hidden gun then
we get to go get it then we wouldn't
know now there's the teaser trailer
where we know about one other one that's
coming so they're like hey this is the
one you're getting now set expectations
they have the toughest line in the world
to walk with their community because
everybody's like I want all this amazing
stuff there's this cool cabal minigun
that's coming okay we get the shotgun as
well which one's coming now and then
some could be like hype and letdown so
it's trying to balance all of that I get
it but I'm with you guys to like hey
here's a quest what do you get as
opposed to you know here's a trailer go
get it
just slightly different feel of I know
what I'm getting versus let's see what
see at the end of the road yeah I want a
shout out I plead the fifth he's like
man they better not do it Shayla the
gala hook I know it's not called Jesse
we know we gonna fight we got our weekly
dose of one go right there no no no gala
one carve daddy listen we're not talking
about bringing it back we're just
talking about if it were the coil accord
that I plead the fifth right would they
do a trailer and Oh fortunately I think
they would because if you remember
behind it came bad thing yeah yeah they
did like it's back it's back in black
but they did all this for us yep galavan
is probably the most iconic that's the
gun they would definitely eat off a
trailer there's no way I could see them
sneaking that one and I'd be shocked if
they did that's what I was able II may
gonna have our normal fight about
but they should come back cuz that'll be
a two-hour show we got uh here monkey
can we get away in do you want it back
or do you
yeah in d2 I don't want it in the sense
of hey do you have gala for Gjallarhorn
for this raid boss because this like
whisper or anything was and all that
like I don't I don't mind them bringing
it back but it's not I don't for
trailers and all that right no but I
mean bringing the gun back itself I'm
okay with it but I don't want it to be
like one of those weapons where like it
was you know like how it's just you just
have you just wanted to use that and
only right hey I don't like weapons like
that at all I don't care if they're
heavy and primary I don't like weapons
that just don't have good counters but
just you don't want to take them off you
know I got you I got you the de facto
those that's alright apparently we hear
you've got one anyway so you're good to
go you don't need another one he's got
one in his house I do actually
really yeah it's in my closet right now
I'm gonna hang it up in my room it's
like this I don't person so it's huge
Marcus how he feels about clump solider
of yourself so you have to cross yeah
what's up with comp sorry we got a we
got ask he's just he just he's picking
on me oh okay he's picking on me piston
I get mad man I can't I mean the Rach
yeah but it's weird for me like I don't
I don't get mad at like losing
I get mad at like the fact that when I
play destiny everything you know I I
think everybody is this but you see the
same loadouts man and it's it's not that
it's bad like I get why it happens you
know I get I get why people use the
weapons that are meta because they're
meta grand people who are good with them
just amplify that effect well right when
we run up against that stuff I'm like
you know I just want to be able to use
different weapons you know I want to be
like true
guard and pull out this random stuff and
just kill people with it but when I do
it you know I can do okay but like it's
like you're not gonna stand a chance
against these couple using anything that
meta yeah and that's it it bothers me it
just bothers me I mean I know what you
be that's I'm going through it right now
with my friend I'm really struggling as
enjoying the laser light show I haven't
really been using it hard lights fun but
it's yeah just I don't know I'm just
having fun with it I'm like look at all
these bricks bro III yeah better point
I'm very angry just I played a lot of
cult last week I play trials last week
all play you know a lot of comp this
week and man you know what it is it's
like okay I get the autos got the buff I
understand that the problem with this
gun that I have is if I've been ranged
to range three and I got a scout in a
post that thing should not be out
shooting me there's no driver and I'm
like bro like come on like that like
it's to the point now I have PTSD hard
life like the minute I see it I guess
shot I run like if someone shoots me
first
I don't even try to counter I was one
and see if I get the shot off first or
better position out you don't I'll flank
or something that you're not beating
that gun like you're not beating I am so
disgusted right now I am literally I'm
gonna snitch Bungie if you listen to it
that gun got to get can do is too much
you watch leader ricochet rounds that's
part of it you know that thing in a gun
it's the range drop off it should there
should be like that that range where you
have something that's it has no range
should have some trouble it's sad and
now with the stability the way it is the
600 got that buff it's crazy right there
you you if you're not taking that gun
and I'm kind of like Marcus in this way
like I'm an anti med I'm a little
stubborn I'm a little antimatter guy
like everybody's using something like
and everybody you know me so I'm trying
different there's really not too many
counters for it and that's marketing
that got me really frustrated it's beat
everything I got oh no you know I was
just gonna say like I mean it doesn't
bother me as much just because I like
auto rifles anyway I don't use it but
like I do i do counter them fairly well
um and I will say this in trials when I
was running up as a 970 person run up
against people who are over a thousand
light and using the Ricochet rounds is
about the only damn chance I had against
people I did you know one guy bouncing
them off the floor at him but I was like
oh these people most rats out here yeah
listen if you're at that light level
going against the 1,000 guys and all
that stuff what artifact but I get it
you got to do what you got to do it is a
but um yeah I met an email or a check
check all right I got it baby hopping
all you have to do is pull up your tweet
when you say hey let me see what's the
the most report and I was just like
updating over the weekend what was five
million kills with hardlight revoke her
was number two raw yeah and it was that
number two was like 2 million kills and
then shotgun thorn or somewhere but ya
know it was by far and away like two or
three hundred percent more than other
weapons it was especially for primary
yeah there was nothing to comparison I'm
all about autos gets them low but I hate
I hate autos from the standpoint of this
just me biased I feel it's an easy gun
to use of course I don't mind they got a
buff my issues just that specific gun in
this matter it's like if you're that hot
lighting baby you're not you're not
really gonna do what's out there a
militia I mean I see was a diet promises
I've seen the thorns
you know revoke I obviously this type is
a living I and I like this I'm not a
stalking but I'd like to see snipers do
anything but I just hate what it's we
have those metas weights that one gun
it's just like man so you don't get
adjusted they're gonna do it they always
do
I don't know what they're gonna do to it
but they will so this week it's on
anomaly if you guys haven't seen so last
week was a little longer range little
more corners anomaly we've done hard
light winning the top Mindbenders dusk
rock blues are two and three this time
so snipers are lower then you got Soros
beloved and then you get into the hand
cannons but I mean hand Canada's have
been living at the top for how long now
and then we finally got hand cannons in
like six seven lake instead of one two
and three so it is nice to at least
shifts up a little bit for sure
[Music]
shift that hard like it just a rage drop
off it I'll be imagine I can't imagine
what I haven't played trials this week
yet but hard light on anomaly I can only
all there every which way corner just
not be able to move we'll see what
happens
so anyway we had a trailer sorry these
happen it's called tangents we do that
at times hashtagging long point fourth
Horseman quest actually dropped did you
guys get your did you get your weapon
hmm I have not have you got it thanks my
wife he was there with me to catch it up
and then we did the I did not let night
before last we got it
yeah nice house yeah you guys got to
have it he obviously you have it as well
right yeah I got it and the catalyst
actually I was the how's it feeling yeah
do you have the catalyst yet Marcus I
don't so describe the reload speed of it
normally I mean to go to burn through
four shots in like a second let me just
reload this thing it's like hold on he's
like from autoloading John wick loading
speed please I was watching John wick 3
when he's doing the lake and throw it
all you have him in that receivers
that's beast but
your guardian did that I was pleased see
that animation like you're there you
pick him up and then like slides them
all in at once Oh that'd be crazy little
neighbor bursts hundreds as well so
normally the reload speed is 42 catalyst
takes it to 78 next two doubles the
reload speed and it gives it a fifth in
the chamber oh I didn't know that so you
know one more and it fires
I literally so I did double this is my
whole review I did I did double shotgun
reserves so you have 20 total in your
clip or 20 total so if you do you can
have four five times over or you can
have five four times over with the
catalyst and the five four times over
you're done with the five before he even
starts firing the fourth set much less
reloading eginning to the fifth so
you're done with the twenty like with
the catalyst before you're done with
sixteen with the other one Wow so much
damage
it's beast slate it's it's a damage and
this is what I was doing we were I was
helping a couple people like run just
whatever is streaming one night and when
you like if you can stagger a champion
or something like that
and they just go down over boom dude
it's just health bar going down it's
it's really really good for those
situation is based around close-range
sidearms right submachine guns or swords
oh and you want to know a better one
switch to a sword heavy uppercut oh nice
that's a hell of a lot of damage in a
very very short period of time so like
when it comes to like if you got people
who can stagger cuz I mean it honestly
should have one of those perks on it
either barrier unstoppable or it should
have unstoppable or overload I think one
of those should definitely be in there
it's not sadly but if you could have
somebody stagger it and go in and do
four and then switch over to sword and
do a big uppercut
man they're not gonna have a lot of
health left go high and reload
everything and do it again mmm so we
talking like it's fair like um like s
escalation protocol shaadi pre nerve
trench barrel flava like it's just
ripping through its oh yeah
like it okay I gotta get my I mean your
five shots it's got a more it it hits
like a truck and kicks like a mule
that's the best way I can describe it
yeah if you don't hold the trigger and I
hold all five I'm looking almost at the
ceiling oh wow
I'm literally next to oil I'm like wow
kick is rip that's gonna let down a lot
like even shotgun reloader perks and not
really helping I haven't tested those
actually specifically just because it
was trying to test it without the
catalyst is big I actually would be
curious to try shotgun reloader
made me a double stack if I can just get
a pair arms with it that might help a
little bit um just like stock though the
catalyst doubles the speed alone so
without those the catalyst is now the
catalyst just so you guys know can come
from the Seraph tower chest the lost
sector chest even somebody said just
from clearing the bunker so if you stick
with the war mind activities good bad
luck or otherwise hopefully you'll get
it knock on something I don't even have
any water around me I just I got out of
my second run and somebody's like luck
so oranjee based you katie is not even a
guarantee yep aren't you yeah just from
all of those tests and activities now
mom kiss for the quest itself and then
your wife can you know give you a little
like handwritten note of her thoughts as
well you guys both went through the
quest what did you what'd you think of
the quest it's okay I mean it was more
or less I guess I guess they try to
throw the whole thing and there is like
a little side mission type thing you
know I thought it was kind of neat how
good to go through the father's office
but the actual like the busy part of the
quest go kill this stuff killer stuff
I'm not to like surprise but that's
pretty typical oh yeah I didn't feel
like I didn't feel like it was more I
don't want the word is it didn't feel
like it was part of like some kind of
story
I don't I kind of got disconnected there
it's just like here do this then that's
this is pretty much yeah just back and
forth here and then a couple things but
just kill go like me yeah yeah go kill
go kill well it turned into go kill 50
Saiyans like okay I did a lost sector
three times over and then go kill either
Mars public events or kill Cabal and I
was like I ran the loss sector and
killed cabal's like dude we have like 4%
what in the living hell is this and then
you finally go and you do a public event
on Mars a real public event is 20%
but what's everybody gonna do as a
collision protocol escalation protocol
so that you're killing hive for a cabal
related quest those like how's that work
mmm-hmm yeah you know what like was
interesting to me like when it came to
weapons and how they introduced me which
I know this was a lot more work but you
know how when that when they brought in
the world whisper quest and the outbreak
prom or outbreak perfected that was that
was cool because like you actually had
this fault like you actually had
something that was going on there and
you were brought back to the tower which
was neat but you also had a fallen that
had stole or supposedly stole this
weapon you know which was kind of kind
of cool cuz you're racing through the
tower you know trying to head him off at
the curve I guess boertie um but like I
like that I like that because it felt
interactive I didn't feel like I was
mindlessly killing things I felt like I
had a goal I had a mission it was timed
it was tough you know yes of course
doing that for every exotic they bring
back would require a lot of work yeah
actually you know but um but those are
the kind of things that I find
interesting because you know you're you
actually get the experience that with
your friends and you're all like you
know cussing at each other because you
fail what did you just die what Trevor
okay seriously calm down it's Trevor
that was awesome you know it makes
Ashley made shirts out of that you know
like a magical moment
don't you just love to keep these things
around please don't show what is a
little internal augment but request
would you exotic to go away but moving
on 3:05 guess we good do that we got a
guest definitely I hear what you guys
say look from the outside look at it I
just got the beginning of the quest more
like maybe Step two or three and so far
I kind of feel a bunker spills but it's
like you know it started off cool I like
the idea of going in there you know
Cevallos special vault
you know he's office and I was looking
around and stuff like shout it's a
violin off yeah I looked he got a trials
chest he's got like a lighthouse chest
is yeah what you're doing at the
lighthouse oh so I did a lot longer than
you have so yeah move it around I said
you know I was messing around with the
little platforming inside you see the
fall you see it's been stolen you go
back so the beginning I felt had
promised I like that but as it went on
you speak to N and it's like public
sector or in this and in Sion Carol and
this and it just that's where I kind of
got disconnected and it just felt busy
work busy work prisons work and I didn't
feel any emotional attachment to the
weapon you know I'm saying I didn't feel
like you know they kind of connected
that and and again I get it like like
Marcus said again we can't get a a
whisper in a Cyril our every single time
but I do wish especially with exotics
maybe there's another way they can
introduce it with some with some lore
that it really gets you excited about it
and last thing you know II mean you've
talked about this at nauseam is like
stuff like um Tommy's matchbook and
symmetry I just hate that would you log
in and that's the battle pass here you
go exactly it it's just like there's no
context it's just you got the battle
pass you're we giving you a free exotic
yeah give me a quest or something to
give me a little attachment to the guy
now I've always felt that way about it
let's see how they go moving forward you
know I'm saying they definitely were
excited they put a trail out about it
but I got to get the gun I gotta get to
get because I definitely hearing good
things I'm actually hearing good things
about it in people see that I would be
surprised I uh maybe it's a little
better range this time around in d1 the
range was like - that thing you had to
be next to the people that's why it was
mostly good pv e I don't know I mean
you'll say that we're okay no I say
cross I think Ross got a video he was
saying that um I think shotgun range I
got nerfed or whatever it is yeah he
said I think it I think it falls outside
of it it's like nine but it's like a
it's a it's like a Bronco like you
should decay and it's you know it's a
it's all over the place so you got to
deal with that but I heard like you know
it'll - you could really put somebody
down with it okay if you get that
perfect range before a super hits you
and you just look and you dump like a
decent sized clip you'll put a lot of
damage out it just kind of depends if
you can get in range and also rein in
that bucket bucking bronco because it
will definitely kick you to the ceiling
yeah but I mean I'm I'm with you guys as
well because it did feel felt like
busywork you had however many kills in
public events sorry
wolves are outside you guys can hear
that salad is wolf salut yeah my - so
yeah it was like do that and then it was
like silence I was like I did the law
sector first it's like there's like 14
Cylons in there so I did the lost sector
three times but then you find a chest
and it's like 20% like okay and then the
last one is go kill I ended up doing
just the public events just to kill
enemies I think whatever the last piece
was was just that was the monotonous of
I think most of them cuz at least an
escalation protocol I'm going through
waves and it's just you know it's
checking the percentage box I think the
last was just kills whatever it was and
it just took a while and wouldn't you
say this start of it sets up with links
of all of us bla words Cevallos office
that was really cool to go in little
Tower section like you saw like dying
hydras tweeted out on Twitter it's like
hey when you guys see it in there see if
you guys catch anything and then all of
a sudden that part sets it up cool and
you get busy work in the end and you do
the legendary lost sector and you just
get the gun there's like there's not
even like a close
inquest discussion with is evolving the
Impala hey thanks for getting this I
gotta polish it up let me load it up let
me look and something as opposed to last
sector gone done like that is just like
anti climactic ending it's like if
you've run the legendary lost sector
like I got my gun so it's just it didn't
have the time and I know it's a d1
exotic and they're bringing it back and
hopefully they treat the other one the
giant Cabal minigun or whatever this
season a little better and I don't
always expect it all the time but I
would rather have less exotics delivered
better than more exotics just kind of
dumped in with busy work if that acts
just my opinion
no facts completely agree
so that was the big one and then if you
guys didn't hear for about three or four
hours the final step of the quest was
the legendary lost sector that wasn't
even active so did you hear about that
since I know you had yeah so there's a
specific legendary loss sector the
quarry that you have to run but for
about the first three or four hours it
was not that loss sector on Tuesday so
every streamer went through the same
step together and they got to a wall and
they like guess we'll see it tomorrow or
Thursday depending on when this thing
pops up and everybody's like wow I'm
time gating much and then Bungie tweeted
out later we switched it Wow they
switched it pretty quick that's crazy I
don't know I don't remember who tweeted
it where some I was maybe fallout or one
of them said something by the in town
gated and I know we ran through it I'm
like where was the town gated port I
don't understand I didn't know that
mm-hmm
danos asking do you think fourth
Horseman should have been with the past
and time again the quest honestly for a
d1 exotic to come back I drove it at the
d1 be like hey here's a view an exotic
we brought back new gun involves a quest
at least give me that sweater oh you
prefer the obvious like okay I would
like if something's gonna be given to me
in a battle past give me the thing I've
seen before let me go journey to the new
one I still don't want anything there
but if I have to guess we don't yeah
mmm-hmm what else we got
so I mean that was the quest we got that
one that was the major thing this week
we've got really nothing else going on
in the PvE section stories still kind of
hanging next week we get the new bunker
that one's gonna be on the moon so we're
gonna have to I don't know if there's
gonna be a little cinematic of that
ground opening up or not but we'll get
to see the new bunker and level that one
up and just kind of wanted to see if you
guys maxed out your etz bunker yet you
guys done with that how are you guys
enjoying the war mind grind or my bit
grind gambit sighs your bits looking
mocking up the bits okay not so good
right now I mean I haven't had as much
time to play this season so far
just cuz there's a lot happening but we
like we've seen you know we had undying
and we had a season of Dom he's a good
one and now this one and each one
respectively is had its own little
grindy like things and I'm not saying
that I don't like it but I'm at this
point I'm kind of like oh you know I'll
get it
you know I'm dying like I straight burn
through that thing like you know I
grinded and grinded to get everything
mm-hmm you know to get the title and
everything and then when it's just
slowly I'm getting to the point where
I'm just like alright I'll get to it if
I get to it if I don't I don't you know
I'm just not as I'm not because it I
guess it's the repetitiveness of it oh
my god it feels like the thing yeah I'm
just doing a different thing like some
controversy hey I need to ask you a
question oh so what I'm getting from you
Lord Marcus here is that arm got really
afraid so far this season
annual slash annual pass structure with
these grindy activities and you kind of
maybe prefer the old expansion format
don't have a preference I mean I get
both ways I don't know kind of how I'm
not biased or one or the other because I
get why they're doing it this way and I
know that they're trying to keep players
interested
you know because back in d1 and things
when yet expansions there were some dry
times I mean yes yeah you got a pretty
pretty lackluster for a while yes
so I get this it's just that I think
with the way that it's it's coming
across every season to me I love the
story and I love that they're
introducing new characters or characters
back from the dead you know which is
awesome to me um I just I think the
structure of how they're going about
having to do things is keeping people
busy but I I'm starting to just see past
that every time now and I'm not saying
it's bad because it is good to have
something to do to keep running to give
you goals for the next season it's just
that I don't feel like I'm actually I
don't feel like the goals are like worth
it the juice isn't quite worth the
squeeze yeah I mean I like some of the
titles but yeah unless you're trying to
chase there right right like the grind
be nature's of a bunker or an obelisk in
Allah you know like grinds I just want
my grind to be something that you know
worth me putting however many hours I
put in an undying which I put it you
know cuz you know I'm saying like I've
got a lot of hours to get all that stuff
in and again I got a title which I'm
happy about but looking back I'm like
you know you're wrong on that was the
same thing with dawn for me dawn was
probably my most casual season because I
did a lot of XP bounties I checked the
boxes for the sundial I know there was I
forget who it was I was talking to her
somebody was like I ran the sundial five
times the whole season and they still
have a title they did like yeah specific
like they did the minute the flawless
they did this they stayed alive when we
killed you know Tom done never had to do
it again and yes yeah yeah and it's been
weird and you said it right it's like we
had altered right like rise of iron to
d2 was just like where is one thing to
do versus now here's always something to
do but it's like the busywork so it's
like is the shorter is less
stuff but more special stuff more member
molars always having little stuff but
you're bored when you're doing it
it's hot it's really hard especially as
they have less resources now than they
even did before how do you ask them to
be like hey I want more stuff okay they
have a season pass well what if the
season pass was just September and then
they did a 6-month thing and they did
now if there was none like that's like
how do you or you did four months
instead of three so they didn't have
this continual Kate it's like whatever
timing for them I would be curious like
what four months to be better what six
months to be better or you guys would
just you would it be better if you just
like here's content for a year
iron banner would come up trials would
come up you keep your maintenance you
got your raid here's your max level you
guys have a beer next year big old
expansion comes out I mean we've had
this little you cog Nia and I have had
this discussion over dry times and how
much I eat and how quick we can get
content and it's always and we and now
we're kind of getting the other side of
here's these little seasoned dunkers
while two-thirds of the studios working
on d3 or September whatever it is and
it's just really hard to know it's hard
to ask for more because we know they're
limited especially now with everybody
being like working from home it's not
gonna be any better but on the other
side I was just gonna say on the other
side we're kind of like if we get
another six-person match made activity
and a grande obelisk in season 11 people
are gonna be like dude I'm just gonna go
play something else like 9 mmm and
that's the thing like I don't feel like
they're doing it wrong I think that
they're doing they have the right setup
to keep people busy but you you can't
just give people mindless things to do
you have to they have to have a reason
to want to do these things and I'm not
saying that's cosmetic stuff or whatever
but like even like the dart effect that
was a good that wasn't good because
people are like hey yeah I can get my
light level to 10,000 or whatever you
know yes I'm gonna grind this until I'm
dead and that's what some of them do but
and that's cool but like there's there
just needs to be something in there to
keep people fresh on it and to say oh
this week I'm doing the ball
stuff but this week it's different from
last week there's a chance that I'm
gonna get this and maybe let that rotate
you know um because in the end people
are gonna complain that when something
doesn't drop for them but they're gonna
keep doing it until they back you know
what I'm saying
so like have rotations in it have things
have percentage drop rates that people
want and they're gonna keep doing it
that week that it pops up they're gonna
be there you know and stuff like that
not you I'm sorry if I got you
no no yeah man this is tough I mean I
know I know what you're getting at and
um it's it's tough because my thing is
this I'm seeing a pattern you mean and
um like I said we saw obelisk we you
know we got this um it look I don't hate
it I don't go into like the bunker and
I'm like oh this is terrible like it's
not that type of vibe but it's it's kind
of like what you guys are saying which
like you know kind of like this mindless
thing and and then you you you buy this
thing from the war mine to decrease the
amount of cost its kind of similarly
kind of things and then it's like oh can
you buy this thing
that's gonna give you this currency to
drop while you do the other activities
and yadda yadda yadda and then next week
they're all the week after it's gonna be
this bunker and this obelisk that's you
starting to see what it is and and
listen I know from a resource standpoint
you know they're working on d3 for my
understanding they're also working on
that other game I believe it's called
matter there's another gaming working on
so essentially the vibe I'm getting is
d2 current team is kind of like the B
team
um saying this is like a smaller group
doing that while they got these things
Li's tell them that by the way no salute
to y'all here keeping us tonight Sarge
you know listen I just gotta call out it
I can't honestly say that this is
substantial content I can't do I'm not
disrespecting anybody over there I'm
just saying that from what
what we're getting right now you know
it's kind of like this obelisk II thing
you know say and this may have to be
until September cuz we clearly have it
got you know since uh but it's a shadow
keep I've got a dungeon we haven't got a
red we know those take resources we know
that's not an easy thing to create I'm
not gonna disrespect them and say hey I
want to raid everything come on okay
that's just ridiculous
so my thing is you know they they have
to I don't I I don't envy them because
they're in this weird position where you
know they have to keep the game of flow
and they have to also provide
substantial content so that people don't
go away from the game then I'm saying
but at the same time you know it's it's
tough because you know you got the hawk
all right now you know say hey I don't
have incentive to play I don't there's
not you know that that's kind of the
murmuring going on right now the hawk or
maybe you casual guys alright but the
hawk or like this is not you know
getting me revved up getting the juices
flowing and now all I'm worrying about
is you know long-term what can they do
to this you know annual pass structure
to juice it up to get people still
excited every time a new one dropped so
that's that's that's a tough one I don't
know how they're gonna try to navigate
it but um I can understand you know
there's some people are like hey I'm
taking a break right now I'm playing
this I'm playing that or you know that
kind of thing and and look I love trials
is bad you know but obviously not
everybody's a pvp guy like me I'm in
heaven I'm loving it you know saying but
some of the PvE community is like yeah
I'm not really feeling the rest of the
content or no and nor my trials I get it
yeah well I mean even soldier said
something true yeah it's like I but say
the same thing he said I mean they got
next-gen consoles coming out whether
they're delayed or not they got to make
a version of destiny - oh were these
consoles cuz you're just gonna be cross
play boot up your new console people
here to be playing 4k 60 frames field of
view on console new PS 5s there's a
difference in the architecture they got
to do some work there too and that's
just not an overnight fix they've got
dev kits in there they're working with
oh yeah so you have like a third
generation another game you're trying to
keep people like active in your current
content there's not enough people to
make this stuff go around so it's that's
kind of the point where
you log in and you see it's like this is
I guess where the when you look at the
calendar and you're going hey I got a
bunker and I got a tower
well the towers are active already on
every planet so that's not exactly new
so we're that's gonna be the same thing
kind of all season at least for about
six weeks they don't have a date of
anything past about there then we have a
bunker for two weeks bunker for two
weeks and bunker for two weeks
well I'm like I've saved up I mean this
is what we're looking at and I've saved
up close to 2000 warmind bits from this
one I'm maxing it out so it's like when
I go over to the next one boy I'm really
I'm working from home a lot so just say
wow you you out there you do it you do
it the repeatable bounties I will say
are easy because you just pick up if I'm
be like hey I'm gonna go do something
with other weapons whether it be the
public event or strikes or crucible and
just be like hey you go hit up some
bounties go match up my weapons cool and
it's not it's an easy like repetitious
process but it is very repetitive but it
was like if I stock up enough this week
and then I do the next bunker and I'm
like okay I'm almost done and I play
some weeklies and get those up and if
I'm like two or three weeks down the
road I'm kind of going just scratching
my head to wonder it's like I've
upgraded the bunker fully I've what what
else am i doing if I've upgrade all the
bunkers and I you know make sure
Rasputin can talk to all the bunkers and
I even buy those things in advance how
how much more is there you - Celebi on
this car - no I know you got sounded
enthused brother and that's the hard
part about this this is where I don't
envy bungees job
they're big Oh kisses trials you can
tell but tweeting out about the map
every Friday they're staying up on like
the loot they've got the the big pieces
trials this season and then the meanie
stuff is kind of a I don't wanna say
mindless grind but it's not far from
that because it is bounties bits and a
currency and it's tough but it was like
why are you laughing so hard at me I
should be honest I'm just your toy he's
like it's bounties bits in it you so
defeated
like be best with your buddy right
I was like I look at the calendar and I
know what my next four weeks are I do I
already know what my next four weeks are
and there's not there may be a quest
that drops there may be a little maybe
there's a little teaser trailer of a
moon bunker opening or we get to see
Zavala and Anna in two other bunkers but
I don't expect a lot for a month so
that's just that's that's just where it
is different me the reason why was
laughs it's just that remember by paid
the last three or four seasons
yeah with no trials or whatever right
and as the Pvt guy I was so frustrated
so it's full funny to see how the tables
have flipped a little bit and I'm like
I'm living my best life
you're like ponies bunkers bits it's
just hilarious right now but to your
point
like we said we always over the Wii you
could throw in there but III aro envy
them because they're in a tough spot
you know they're in it's us but more
only thing is I only thing I worry is we
have to be realistic right as as gamers
we're realistic from the development
standpoint but there's also that thing
that I worry that you know if too many
people feel that it's banana sand not
substantial do they start leaving gay
you know I'm saying and that's my only
because you know we all know this game
we don't want no one to go away from it
but people need you know emotional
investment they need to feel a reason to
log in every day and I just you know
hope they don't stray too far while at
the same time trying to manage resource
it's it's a juggling act and I don't I
know area man it's a tough position to
be in
well speaking of rewards perfect said
way we got to talk about the weekend
activity that you've been all sorts of
gritted about and then monkeys as well
have you jumped into the world of trials
since you of course make like the art
for it
have you been playing the game behind it
yeah I didn't actually this has been
interesting for me this is kind of a
segue but it ties into it a promise and
we go down a huge danger cause all we do
is tangent so what we do is tangent
yeah continue um in d1 I didn't get to
play trials because like I said I played
oh I played on xbox and I didn't have
anybody that played with me sounds
lonely
but tag brother good dude no idea like I
played time but I really didn't have
anybody to play with on in d1 most
because my real life friends Dahl them
like they didn't really play destiny or
mini-games at all and then it wasn't
until d2 that my wife actually started
playing and when that happened of course
then I have plenty of I had her to play
with but also had some other friends
that we met that we currently play with
and so this year is the first year they
actually got to experience trials and
I've done plenty of comp play and things
like that but I get to play trials you
know doesn't active let me hear this
yeah and so you know I jumped in there
at 960 something and we did okay like we
didn't do horrible there were some teams
um you know we had to whip out the
snipers on people who were up in the one
case because this is like it's hard to
hard to really fight somebody from 960
up to over a thousand yeah but we we
lost the majority of those matches just
because of mostly power level I mean
they would survive supers and oh wow
yeah I am that wasn't super and it's not
the strongest part of the attack but I
was on the Stryker and I did this the
charge the shoulder charge area which
would normally kill a regular Guardian
no it didn't you know it's just like you
know that's not that's one of those
things when you're playing you're so
used to it happening that you move on to
the next person well when you do that
that person still alive he's just gonna
there's stuff like that but all in all
it was fun I just kind of was kind of
like I think the power level gap was a
little bit too extreme
um I don't mind having the power level
in there I just think like thirty and
forty power levels it's like whoo you
know that's the that's alive yeah but uh
we did have a good time
and how she has scars well um I mean we
we were we really only did like three
wins I think that's probably about as
high as we got mm-hmm Mina or we had to
scratch every card yeah that's probably
I'll be don't worry if I ever jumped
yeah I'm gonna be on the same boat
what about you cut you know oh um let's
hear the thoughts of the return of the
amazing thing that is trials of Osiris
Osiris I mean oh good oh good
obviously what's ain't got my got my
mercy boon and then we test that bad boy
you know into all of it smallpox no pus
remember we talked about that quest yes
do you know what that was what the nine
just to be nine you had to be 968 click
a button yeah yeah that was that's kind
of wack we were we had talked about that
as like kind of a cheating prevention
thing to be hey you got to get to 960
second a place um and then if you up
there then you know a little a decent
quest to do one time so people don't
wanna repeat it a lot you just have to
be high enough I thought that was like
that was like the tweet was kind of
misleading yeah you're right that's a
good point that's a good point forgot
all about that because our concern with
the cheaters and we wanted to give them
a little bit of a hurdle if they get
banned to come back in not to be able to
just boom right back at light level
created in our own home so I forgot
about a good point yeah I forgot all
about that so yeah that was that we got
the versus we started up and um you know
for the trials fans you know that that
initial map that I wasn't even in last
week's it's such a iconic I mean that
dad is literally like arguably like one
of a perfect trials map so it's no good
to be out there you know you're running
when you call out you're doing this
stuff it felt really good
we got we got we got about five about
five then things started getting a
little sweaty we started seeing the
power level stuff we started seeing all
that craziness I started to learn the
pain of hard light and uh thanks but um
you know there was some really good
sniper some really good teams it's just
it's such an adrenaline build mode and
just you know that they're sweaty
and paid attention and stuff like that
not going off too far so you don't get
picked there's a lot of little nuances
to it that I've missed and I love that
it's back so um yeah I mean I got the
five I got the UM my brownies done and I
got the Scout shot the cool guys had a
good video this guy he said it's
actually pretty good I'm just kind of
wait for role the cool thing is if you
unlock a weapon every trials coin you
have that goes as currency towards
Osiris you keep cashing in towards
random roles for any weapon you've
already acquired so it's like it's like
an open bounty that you just like buy it
with tokens once you've got it once so
basically once you've got it once the
weapon it drops right yeah it did every
time you play I guess you get tokens and
stuff like that through gameplay you
know once you go to him and you have all
your tokens that isn't opening for
random roles which I like now the thing
that threw me off was the arm a bit
because we were like you know where's
the armor how can you get it and Bungie
Khan explained it it's a rotating thing
you know every week based on the amount
of wins you get so that's a little
different I don't know how I feel
necessarily about that just yet I'm not
like anger but it's definitely different
from the original deal in trials um
overall like my main thing is I guess
the mole feels great I didn't have any
major issues the main thing I have right
now and we talked about it last last
word is the power level thing man and I
know the first week the artifact was it
was enabled still I'll get it right now
I got to see how it is with the artifact
disabled before I make my final comment
because it don't feel good when you
facing them 1080s and I'm 11
it'll feel good baby like I was at
Davison died 79 80 and I was getting
like I couldn't even look at these dudes
more than a second before you get ran
off the sky so you know um we gotta I
gotta see how that working I say if it
still feels the same with the regular
and no artifact have the question power
level in aim and I'm gonna put crazies
I'm the biggest power enable dude from
when I always love that feature I don't
know how I feel about it
lately I don't know you don't say it but
that's where I'm at with it man but now
the mold feels great I'm glad it's back
having a ball to know practice someone
else thing what's up thought the road
wards are fitting right now I have not
acquired all of them I can only go by
what people have a shout out to fall out
heard the shotgun is crazy you know I'm
saying on the scout I'm just not as good
with it and I just don't feel it's dad
strong in this matter no I got it I
tried it there's not a week okay not the
end I think me and soldier he saw her he
mention Co guys review and we're both
just like I don't know it kind of feels
like which you know you know this scout
rifle from the season the undying the
leaves on it the leaves morning yes
imperative yeah parody of a sunlight
yeah yeah that was humongous like if you
felt like you were you literally had
like a big deer rifle but like just the
overall size of it on my screen was so
disorienting oriented yeah this is bad
and I I don't feel like this was just
like that but I kind of had the same you
don't they don't feel yeah I heard
fallout even talking about the shotgun
today is like it's a beefy one like
there yeah apparently they're large
taking up some yeah yeah take up a space
all kind of shotgun is it
what kind of archetype I don't know its
aggressive frame I think it's is afraid
yeah I think it's aggressive fit so um
look I got it I gotta see more on it you
know saying right now I'm leaning
towards like it's in the middle there's
some stuff that people like yeah it's
great it is some stuff that I'm like a
you don't say it's average so I just got
to see more you know I'm saying and I
think what they're doing they're
mimicking d1 would be with the whole
first little but we gotta get there's
still classics that people have they
haven't brought into this yet which I'm
assuming is later trials like doctrine
you know Tom had this classic Trials
weapons that the vibe I get is they're
stringing this along each season you
don't say as far as giving us all the
stuff back in armors back they would be
crazy not to because I mean they yeah
need the content they're just kind of
like span it out yeah now yeah do there
are no adepts that seems to be a pretty
continuous thing I wanted to ask you
about I got actually I got a problem
with that - yes but a lot of people do
yeah I got a prob with that because my
thing is this they've got this new perk
got the name of it it kind of acts like
um celerity yes yes celerity and my
feeling is this if you go float
row you've got to reward those those
that it's you know what they should do
they should almost do it like how the
Sun Dial did remember when you went into
battle passing a sundial and he got to
that point and it gave you that extra
perk and it allows you to choose between
you know having to part stuff like that
at this point if you go to the
lighthouse bungee that that is a feat
that needs to be rewarded you can't give
the guy the same gun guy a twin five got
you he's got to have that intrinsic burg
if you're not gonna give dyrdek you
don't want to give snapshot you feel
that's too much of an advantage fine
give that celerity perk as something as
an extra perk bonus or allow something
to switch that that that to me is an
issue I don't like that there are no a
debt kind of versions or a weapon it be
needs there needs to be a reward and for
my understanding do you know what the UM
what is it the shards anything going on
with the with the flawless run as far as
um like currency tokens yeah it's like
trials coins or whatever they are well
more so like all golf balls a descended
Sean I'm saying I mean I think I was
listening to jerski and stuff on firing
range and he was just saying is like
dude I played all week and I have so
many currencies right now like they're
getting a lot from those runs and I
think people are liking the fact that
it's repeatable like if you get a new
card you go in there you get gear right
so maybe just the fact that it's
repeatable they wanted to not have you
be able to farm adepts per se but I mean
if you go flawless
I think the celerity is you're saying
intrinsic celerity and then maybe a
double perc role like nothing to over
lead at the top but like celerity being
an extra and then have two of the other
ones to give you better chance that your
daughter else scuse me mm-hmm
it's like a mark of like you've attained
that like when that was a good thing
about like indie ones when you saw that
thank you
that person granted the ornaments and
stuff are cool and all but like having a
weapon or something that you got because
you went flawless or you did this raid
and did this boss and like that's
something to be proud of and like other
people are gonna covet that and say I'm
gonna do trials I don't know go flawless
ding-ding-ding-ding
you know and it's just it gives you
people more incentive to want to do it
be like yeah I got this weapon I worked
my ass off for it but I got it you know
hangs yeah even if it was just like they
I mean you can shade every weapon now
but like tiny ornaments something to set
like the Adept they don't have to be
crazy over-the-top but some other thing
to set them apart like a different spot
that glows on top of the normal glows a
little bit extra for an adept weapon
with those perks mm-hmm I mean celerity
doesn't seem like it's gonna be game
breaking it's usually like if you're the
last one alive you got those little
negative situation anyway yeah basically
screwed like if you give this one out
you're probably crafty anyway yeah I
just was jumping on that because this is
this is my main beef like gotta call my
peoples out man um the big issue I got
is that I feel since the ritual weapons
have gone away the pinnacles or whatever
it's like they are so against giving
that advantage or any type of advantage
for like the hardcore you know I'm
saying and we've seen things like Lunas
howl and other stuff start to come back
down as far as ease of acquiring you
never saying and I'm just worried like I
missed those days of you know when like
like Marcus said you went to the tower
you expected that Guardian in his weapon
set of death you're like oh okay how did
he get that what he wore to the tower
and you see that glowed like okay like
it incentivizes you to go hard to try
hard to say I want to also acquire that
and I just feel like they've been kind
of going away from that and I think they
still need to give you know the hardcore
community those days because that's what
makes people
want to try hard to attain and I don't
want them to go away from it you know
what they need to like Frank a frame of
mind a good frame of mind would be in my
opinion and I think other people
obviously said this is like instead of
nerf in Lunas house instead of nerfing
this not nerfing but instead of playing
taking its specialness away put in
something from a raid that you don't
have to PvP for that's hard again but
for those hardcore PV ears um let's just
say not saying like let's just say a
weapon like hard light you know didn't
exist in the game but you got it from a
red ball so from a rare quest line drop
from a raid that you could use against
them as how all right hmm
all right you got a weapon there right
now that's broken basically for for
everybody who's willing to use it but
let's just say it wasn't just available
to everybody
all right well immediately you got a
counter like you got two different
weapon archetypes that are pretty lethal
in their own right instead of nerf in
one why don't you just like make a
weapon archetype that's hard to get for
each type of weapon so there's somebody
likes playing with auto rifles they can
go get hard light they can do some
pretty decent damage so one who likes
hand cannons they can grind their butt
off for Lunas how or not forgotten and
do some decent damage so one who likes
bows someone who like you know instead
of nerf in these weapons back down give
them give each archetype their own
special one that's hard to get and so
everybody who likes using pulse rifles
who likes using bows whose license you
know can have their own benefits you
know to me that would keep everything in
line with having a special type of
weapon and people would be more happy
because they can say well he's got
Lunars I'm good with a pulse so I'm
gonna put on and this and you know hand
in hand maybe you know maybe the yeah I
know you to deal with like time to kills
and stuff like that it would be hard to
adjust but I feel like it would be
better than just making everything
mediocre I mean not for you I feel you
man I mean it's a good point I mean I
just want to answer question hold on one
quick that I think W depressed
he said one of the community managers
said that one of the reasons they didn't
do rituals was because they were making
trials weapon would you accept that this
season of trial T didn't push to make
sure they had a strong foundation to
build on and you get a depth or
something like that since they obviously
had a limited amount of time and work
for us to get everything and when
something is they introduced me this is
when I'm gonna be low little bad um
I ain't buying it man cuz it's like
trials was a waste so long you know I'm
saying like trout trials was a way for
like yeah I would say even right so I
kind of had time you know I'm saying now
if you were to say that that took away
the resources you know to do the rituals
and stuff okay I'll let that I'll accept
that but it's just you know I just I'm
kind of where barkis's at in a sense and
I worry about you know these weapons
that you put in a lot of commitment to
the lunes that you know Lunas Howell and
stuff like that and um you know then
they're kind of made easier to attain or
the steps or whatever then they're just
nerfed or change I mean notice and all
that got changed now I forgotten they
got chaining went from one 80s to the
150s I believe you know I'm saying they
change the archetype so you know I'm
just worried about that stuff that I
what they're still to be difficult
things that you know reward people you
know and then I would I'll be okay with
it you know saying what women trials
doesn't have a debt weapons you know and
hopefully they take the feedback you
know people who have said smoking up
though and they spoke it up with the
artifact and they did change that so
what do you feel you know what do you
feel with this whole depth in ritual
stock style weapons kind of changing I
mean I think this discussion is gonna
carry right over when Grandmaster Knight
balls come out same principle we we've
talked about that as I look at you know
ascendant shards and exotic armor as
just common and I'm like I'm gonna go
bash my head through a 1060 nightfall
because the average person may do some
pinnacles pinnacles are going to be
easier around then but you're not gonna
start it then so most people are
probably gonna be not a lot of people
raid do dungeons do trials on the
average so you're gonna people like
maybe 1,001 1,002 on gear score plus an
artifact if you're a decent average
player might be fifteen or twenty your
40th power
elbows below something with about 12
negative modifiers against you yeah
that's the PZ II version of like
climbing the trials Hill and either one
both of trials is longer but either way
both of these activities don't have the
pot of gold at the end that you want to
go for they don't have that valuable
exclusive reward that says I worked my
ass off in this activity and they got
something that is worth yes my time my
effort and it doesn't set itself apart
if I'm just going to go in there and
it's like oh I got another random role
on this lake basic weapon I get a you
know I get a pinnacle drop or something
I'm like right why do I care like that's
the hard part for me and that's the same
thing you guys are saying for trials is
mm-hmm
what what is the point in going flawless
if I can play matches get some tokens
and then at some point it's all gonna
come in the rotation I get in and then I
can literally go play basic matches win
or lose or otherwise and eventually get
all the weapons and armor without having
to go flawless there's no exact eventual
reason to go flows it's just to come
into rotation and that's just cool and
that's why I like Marcus say like they
should introduce stuff like okay if you
go floors maybe you don't get in exacts
but you open up a quest line right
that's unique because you went flawless
and now this quest line leads to an
exotic or this you wait you did the
Grand Master knife alright didn't you
get the chance for this quest line to
drop and then you know almost like a you
know how like izanagi burning a burden
or whatever it is like you they need
some incentive you just can't have
people doing the best highest ceiling
content in the game but they will
rewards are equal to the guys who are
not you don't I'm saying like it just I
don't like that it needs to be a little
bit of disparity and that's that's what
I'm worried about
I think they need to do they can't be
scared of that that's me scared of
balance yep they're so terrified of
balance heroine and the bad thing about
it is like there's been games that have
existed like World of Warcraft is one
that game has been worked and reworked
since the beginning on balance alone
being the thing I can just balance but
the weapons were always very interesting
because you
go into raids and it wasn't about like
you could do a raid for weeks and never
see a drop and then you might have a
chance when it drops to get it yourself
out of a 40-person raid all right mm-hmm
but if you got a certain weapon and raid
you could take the thing into PvP and be
a beast with it on the flip side some
there were people who played that game
never touched a raid but PvP and worked
their way up to what was called a grand
marshal rank or whatever never they
would get weapons that were equivalent
in power to the peoples in the rain they
might not have the same perks but they
were more in tune with PvP and you had
both sides of the spectrum both sides
were happy people who didn't like who
liked PvP they were grind PvP people who
liked rage the ground raids and nobody
really complained when it came to
weapons it was more about like class
abilities and stuff but that kind of in
destiny that's almost out the window
like if you just focused on weapons and
given everybody something good to grind
for they're gonna be there and they
don't matter if you have to do six of
those not the lost sectors you're
talking about are night falls a week to
get a chance at it if there's a chance
they're gonna go for it because that
grind is worth it
Beck's bad I agree that's what it's all
about whether it's worth it or not
whether it's worth it absolutely
completely agree that's what he's gotta
be me yeah well I think the final thing
table was fairly light but we do have
iron banner coming next week we finally
get our point of the stag bow if you
guys have been waiting on that one looks
looks kind of fancy there's a you know
combinations on there it looks like it's
gonna have a curated role so elastic
string natural fletching I can't quite
tell it's tight but you've got first
column with two perks is no distractions
in archers tempo second one is vorpal
and eye of the storm mm-hmm so for boss
damage you could go archers vorpal and
just start firing faster and faster and
pumping that damage in I can actually
see that being decent no distractions I
have the storm I never loved this
weapons becomes more accurate and boost
handling as their health gets lower I
like it slower that's like every
observable that I do there's so much
but it's like there's quite a few perks
that are like when you're in this crappy
situation situation then it activates
that I'm like thank you why do I want to
be next to my deathbed just take
advantage of this thing or die one of
them is actually today um and I was just
like I I know they they at some point
like perks are hard to keep getting
creative on bones like I don't want to
be like really low on health to be like
cool now it's better
what if I'm not low on health what if
somebody's like a god in PvP
they don't use half the gun like okay
cool I know it looks pretty cool iron
banner I'm sure the ornamentation will
be nice but and I mean no distractions
vorpal maybe or archers Templar vorpal I
can see actually getting a decent amount
of kind of use on it but that's just on
bosses though so mmm I don't know that's
next week and but I mean do we expect
much different besides you know smelting
light that's the quest yeah power
advantage will be enabled but artifact
will not as it is currently in trials
this weekend and after that a month of
bunkers and towers I'm sorry and they're
bringing back the what is I don't even
know what armor sets those are they're
like the red dark red and gold 2.0
version of the you know what I missed
from D one guy Barker's gafty I don't
know say like I'm not knocking I'm just
saying like the the sits are nothing in
comparison to day one hmm thanks I just
can't
but like I they're not bad it's just
that I'm just not into them I guess yeah
the standard was set you know what I
mean yeah that's the problem
yeah bro like remember the rise of iron
ones that had like the furnace is going
on those dude it wasn't they had the fur
and you know I'm seeing like we it was
great
instead of armor since when when did we
get a new when's the last new iron
banner set up a boycott with your
one-man recycling is all rhythms these
over and over yeah it's like give me a
set of armor that has like stuff on like
shoulders and chest and legs like
whatever subclass I'm wearing guess what
there's like electricity of my shoulders
there's fire in my stomach oh there's
like a voice log in my knees like type
of stuff dude no but we used to have the
Wolves resources this boy I'm willing to
pay test me like Joe do something man
cuz you can't be bringing this old stuff
out this Walmart deep No do you know how
much money they would make if they
brought back all the old armor as always
are you kidding me raid armor and
everything call it the age of triumph we
will gladly pay for that stuff what you
guys I saw Pope beard tweet something
out and his was basically asking the
prices of the stuff in the ever verse
late no I mean it's always a thing but
it's sling and I know they look into the
games and I'm sure they do
and this is my point of view it's like
some of the sets of armor or the
ornaments and stuff they're like I don't
know it could be like 15 20 don't like
whatever a big set of armor is gonna be
a pretty good chunk like would you I
know I would probably buy like I would
spend the 20 or 30 dollars if I got more
sets as opposed to if one set cost 20
bucks if like three sets cost 20 bucks I
would probably spend 40 bucks because I
feel like I get more I just feel like
everything in that ever verse store that
is for silver is too high yeah don't
talk about this a lot and I I don't buy
a lot of stuff from every verse and I've
bought more recently just because I only
buy it if I'm like am I gonna get this
and wear it like you
it's gonna be something I see is like I
really like the style of this and I know
I'm gonna wear it or I know me and use
this
I'll buy and did I think about the calls
and I'm lucky I'm like this is pretty
expensive but then you know I'm thinking
like it's bungee we're dealing with a
very a lot smaller company here in terms
of what we're used to these days for my
ei or yeah things like that so it's like
if if they're gonna put something up
here they're probably gonna try to at
least make it worth their while and you
know granted it might be a little
overpriced but you're paying a company
that's gotten pretty limited resources
for what they're trying to do so I don't
mind it because I'm not buying
everything that they put up there either
you know there are some people there's
like you know they want a lot of stuff
that's up there and then they're they
get into the motive this shouldn't even
be on their reverse this should be in
the game which is that's a whole
different ball yeah yeah that's another
discussion yeah yeah I mean yeah it's
it's a bit pricey I'm in the same boat
to like if there's some things that I
know if I'm going to wear or it's on and
exotic that I know that I use yeah bro I
go for it when they threw that you know
how they got me eat they know I'm such a
trials for him I've seen those Osiris
versions of throw that outbreak frog got
purchased a frog with the logo with the
I I was like all buzz you you did it
again here goes the credit card let's go
swipe yeah I mean listen there's certain
things like anomalies but that but yes
some of this stuff is really pricey yeah
you need to kind of you know figure it
out in can we get some sales every once
in a while can we get a sale they have
some but they're not they're not that
great you know buy 3 armor sets for like
do you like if you occasionally just do
like your clearance sale like some of
this crap is old let me let me spend 15
bucks in kena sure of some ornaments
here or something like that I would
spend more if it wasn't all like if an
ornament was at $8 I'm like we move guns
around enough like but if it was like 3
or 4 and probably might like $10 worth
as opposed to not buying the eighth like
Mike's the point where I would probably
spend more if the value was better for
me so how much would you pay for like
Kings fall raid Armour or as ornaments I
mean they can take my wallet I don't
know look like that then especially if
their ornaments yeah then all talk but
like yeah I don't know I'm just messing
no no for sure like those would be a mag
there's some things I'll a code epic so
I'm is that day that goes me I've got
like principles in everything oh it
looks like that is just a toy a what's
funny is they sitting on a ton of this
stuff they said not a ton of this stuff
they wanted to do it though yeah yeah
they had the assets they just got to
rework them - mmhmm it within the game
I'm a 2.0 and all that good stuff
yeah that's what I guess I admit I would
be a very weak I would in a heartbeat if
I could walk around like the what is it
what is the age of triumph that was
called a trial you're trying to miss
yeah the aging tripe crota armor soul
yeah I was I would drop I would drop the
Tony on that and be like you brought it
back you did to eat like you had to
rework it I understand but you even
brought it back and I'll pay more for
that one but just none after seeing
those indie one yeah they screwed up d2
because now they can't match it you have
like the Ziva armor that has like the
little floating shoulder pad little
thing that keeps coming on and dude they
were so so good so uh taking King -
those were those were I like the crota
one like stuck out more but like I love
like the crackling kind of the lightning
underneath and the ticking kid those
were earnest yes I'd even pay for the it
was a default of glass but I had a
little while signal
they sent us some stuff bad so funny was
was the Oh what is it the wrath of
Rasheed warlock he always had like a
mattress kind of funny outfits but
iconic outfits man very very good
artwork absolutely those guys they they
really do a fantastic job with the
design a lot of the stuff they ever
decided to bring it back up there oh
there we go yeah I found the list of him
now I was gonna ask you one thing about
trials like how do you like saying
fourteens voice oh yeah I think he did
one where like I sniped a guy or
something he he said he says something
but I was just like it was just out of
nowhere
yes hey yo he's a trip like you know
you'd be like I will tell the children
he goes off with his head but he's
falling like I mean I don't you know
like I said once ours never his wife
she's never in the game tell he was
shacks who did travel Saracen d1 but
it's fun to have him he's just
aggressive he's hilarious you don't know
what he's gonna say it's really good I
definitely do like that aspect of it and
the only thing I want to say before we
close out um I do like that thing that
they implement I know we've been kind of
digging on him about things we don't
like about child I kinda like that thing
they're doing with the emblem and then
if you help someone go flawless or on
the way in some reward I like that so
again they do it some things I like but
again we've got to work on the little
weapons and stuff but yeah shout out to
my man you know saying seek 14 spice it
up trials with all the Russian craziness
thing he said if you're Jane I do like
it I do enjoy it yeah the lightness of
it breakers mmm I know we never actually
get a group together to work on trials
I'm just gonna see bread stop signs in
front of me everywhere that's all I
expected like I'm over here on the white
side don't hurt me well yeah I was like
it is a lighter week and I mean trials
definitely enjoy it
weekend anything else you got kognito
before we wrap this up and let this man
get back to his family
okay well there's priorities that's good
you know excuse me
horsemen and other than that man just
ready go go go get your quest we'll
grind out those bits gotta get ready I
know I did the smartest thing though
even though I don't got everything done
I got the one that for every activity I
do I get the random shape yeah so that
was your one hour Ryan if you guys don't
know grind up a cost first so everything
keeper and then go on down like from the
right like three columns in the third
one in the bottom of that yeah go do
crucible matches go do and that was the
thing like I was like drew ski was
saying when I heard him say something
somewhere is like I have like five
thousand bits because I've just been
playing constant crucible and every
sauce and you'll get a drop of like 22
or 30 when you play it's like ate a whop
yeah so absolutely yeah that's what all
it was it was a pleasure been Fanning
your art as long as I've even seen it
pop through my Twitter I was like that
follow first time I saw one that was
just like that's amazing follow then
just everything since then is like
oh god that I saw uh I think I have it
open let me see the first one I'm always
curious like are there older ones
because I'm looking at like just your
Brian Marcus are to see the drifter down
there Sonic and then those into Lauren
salad and is that kind of are there ones
that are older than that of those as old
as you go he's got like a March station
P has so so like this is interesting if
you didn't know like if you go to
bungie.net some of the avatars they have
of their mind like this stuff yeah the
little cartoon ones yeah um so you tell
my Styles earlier I do
I kept dude cartoon stuff too I can mmm
like them like budget-ass things a
little the little
Hunter with the celestial Nighthawk and
everything that's one of mine I think
there's a warlock with a name but anyway
yeah but no there's some older ones the
ones from d1 that are in black and white
they look like they're done in pencil
mmm
the proto warlock the the Kings ball
hunter and there's a Titan too with the
arms from the strike from the brothers
the Cabal brothers from the and all the
shield brothers yeah yeah way too much
time in that strike so yeah those three
are probably my oldest of more realistic
stuff before that it was all cartoons
and like TV stuff nice
yeah I'm somewhere in the lord saladin
slash Kings fall when either of those
popped up probably like I think the
salad would may have been one of the
first but that's probably one of the
ones I remember just sick and I was like
okay this is awesome and then just kind
of the aurochs one just and anywhere in
that realm I just been yeah that was it
it wasn't even that long ago about a
year so much longer like yeah I don't
know it feels like so much longer since
like we [ __ ] at Guardian Con last year
and stuff which crosses figure that was
Faison yeah I'm preparing I mean we're
not cancelling anything until they
cancel but I'm just like pressing well I
was listening to it was myelin games I
think and then him in game of trap they
were probably like across from you guys
they were saying and I don't know if
this is the same for you so please if
you guys like this get Mansart please go
online and buy it because I know if
Guardian con they said there's was like
fifty percent of their sales for the
year was from guarding like they got a
ton of sales from Guardian con like they
got a big chunk I don't know for you
guys to be that big but if it was yeah I
mean Guardian cons really generous but
you know most of the people they're like
there's a lot of destiny fans there and
oh yeah I mean we do well there oh I'm
like I work a full-time job so
like this is like side stuff sign Popolo
gamma trap in my line in them this is
what they do
especially gamma trout like he's he does
our full time so like it means a lot for
him yeah when Guardian con is cancelled
and
any artists when a con is cancelled and
if you're a regular like exhibitor at a
con it's gonna hurt you yeah so there's
a lot of artists this year actually
hurting but no I mean while I appreciate
it it's not like my main source I'm not
like I'm more disappointed and honestly
I'm more disappointed I'm not gonna get
to see a lot of people like it was
between this year in the last year I
think the craziest things have just
become closer and friends and more
people that have met and like talked to
and had on the podcast and stuff I'm
like I just want to buy like the entire
like convention a drink basically
because of so minute with people in know
if it doesn't happen it's just gonna
hurt my wife actually had a really good
vacation out there too cuz she's like
you go to the convention and I'm going
to sit by she was chiller
she had like the best time she was just
like I didn't have to care about you and
I was like this big yeah I was like okay
cool your best vacation was when I was
not involved in most she gots a
completely relaxed just like she's like
hey I'm gonna go sushi cool I'm gonna go
have sushi hey I'm gonna grab a treat
and who's just she's just like didn't
have to care about anything she's she
loved it so it's like we enjoyed that
half of it to so I'm like I'm I'm hoping
things die down but honestly like you
just we got to do what we got to do you
know even even if they do the bad part
about all this I think they're still
gonna be a lot of people who either a
canceled a lot of their plans or they're
scared to go yeah we're and and that's
gonna be a concern for a while in
everything I feel like just because even
once this stuff dies down you know
there's still a matter of it resurfaced
thing you just don't people gonna worry
you know mm-hmm I was not to be a downer
but you know no it's fair we got to play
safe even somebody was just saying it's
like you know flights from here to here
they were just straight-up like American
cancelled him or something so it's like
yeah some stuff just isn't going to
happen in
just a bummer so mm yeah
for everybody out there stay safe don't
go out if you don't have to if your job
is still making you do it send them a
few news articles see if they'll catch
the drift that we should be staying home
yeah especially this man between us on
the podcast here like hopefully you can
stay home as well so we just have to be
at work but I don't have to be in
contact with people now good okay okay
go put up a CDC like plastic over your
office door or something seriously it
has man yeah yeah well that's all we got
man
the if you guys are watching the video
the leaks are kind of on screen Brian
Marcus art but if there's anything you
want to tell them we're to follow you
anything you got coming any pieces
you're working on these stuff they can
expect let me know anything and
everything they can to find you this is
your time sir sure you can follow me on
any of my social for the Instagram
Twitter Facebook YouTube and twitch
which I'll be streaming more once we
actually get into our new home within
the month
and I think that's about all of them are
gonna be mr. Lucas Instagram it's Brian
Lucas and that's pretty much it so any
of those platforms
just look for Brian Lucas or mr. Marcus
and you'll be you'll find me and yeah I
appreciate the time guys get your coming
on man it was a pleasure believe me so a
little quick wrap for you but I'm sure
you guys are gonna have an interesting
chat oh yeah bring myself to listen to
that one yeah you might need to stay
away of course with twitter at lord
Cognito and all youtube iron lord
podcasts it's going to be most likely
with all the new systems that uh came
out the x-box series extech reveal the
playstation 5 tech deep dive we got get
into that we will have will be hood on
he's a big charitable member of the
gaming community so we'll have him
and maybe we have some surprise guests
we'll see what happens bought oh yeah I
look forward to us every Sunday 1:00
p.m. Eastern is the Lord's Day so check
us out on YouTube we will go live we
will talk all the stuff and prepare for
King to have some things to say about
marks Ernie's uh literally exhilarating
granted I will be I will give 100%
credit like that was a jesus that is not
what we wanted right now so I'm just
gonna say I'm a little bit that's that's
fine but it was like yeah we need some
more for the PlayStation fans but yeah
you definitely gave the Xbox fanboys
ammo to just crap that one bringing in
I'm bringing in some place they should
reinforcements as cameo don't worry it
will not be you know we go can we go
play this thing fear your card out of
line that's gonna go no you trust me I
got I got I got somebody good I got
somebody good he ain't go baby keep
kicking check but at least some more
information
yeah so look forward to that bit again
so Lou to Brian Mauck is for coming on
the last word a lot of fun a lot of
knowledge against guy has tremendous
artwork if you haven't seen it please
check out the website it's fantastic and
many he puts out more warlock stuff he's
getting more no pressure anything you
got a guarantee right here guaranteed
sale if you ever venturing outside in
games how I know you were saying world
of work after you played how far back
does your health went what order some of
your early games like early favorites
real quick how far you want to go I was
gonna say like I was 8-bit Nintendo so
I'm not sure how old you are probably
our age 30 I'll be 36 this year so yeah
yeah be 37 in July yeah I would be very
basically what I will say if you ever
look up the character not asking for a
commission but I'd like your style of
like the destiny art for Chrono Trigger
I
be really curious what that would look
like if it ever like trips into your
minds there's so much what's great about
those games is that there's so much
nostalgia for a lot of our age range and
for little people a little bit younger
too um and anybody who's picked it up
that like they do well like when you see
fan art of that stuff it does really
well not not just in sales but like
people like seeing it you know because
it's like it's one of those things
anytime I'm perusing through artwork and
I see like something that's old-school
you know that brings back memories I'm
like that's a really cool take on that
you know and I start looking the artists
more because you're like you recognize
something you know you love stuff like
that but yeah yeah definitely I mean I I
have to get into more artwork and I'm
hoping that wants to start streaming
I'll start tossing in some destiny piece
and then interweaving some other stuff
with it nice well looking forward to
seeing all the things that come from you
sir for me you guys know I'll be
streaming I'm gonna be kicking my own
ass and Neill or at least the games
gonna be doing it for me
and if I get a random group together who
wants to go goofer in the trials you
guys might see me streaming I don't know
but I'll be streaming a lot basically
find me here if you're not here but if
you catching it in video or audio form
twitch.tv slash yvonne tests do you want
to sever if you trip over a cheetah and
my name you're probably in the right
place but for episode 95 again mr.
Marcus Brian it has been an absolute
pleasure thank you and so jealous of the
talent but enjoy watching it come
together I appreciate it so much man
well thank you guys in chat this has
been awesome
don't go anywhere I want to send you
guys over always like to raid somebody
with any other viewers out here but at
the end of every one we try and end it
if you have ever heard fire team chat
where they end it and try and say it
together
I had joys of editing I could make us
say it together at the end of every
podcast we end it saying the last word
hence the title so I'll wrap it up and
when I kind of give you a little
pregnant pause that's where you kind of
say the last word and I'll get it in
there so so yeah episode 95 March 20th
thank you our special guest Brian Marcus
Marcus art Brian Marcus art calm thank
you go check out our Lord's podcast find
me streaming and for this
episode it has been the last worker